[Music]
as the entertainment World regs from the
death of Matthew Perry some of his
friends co-stars have taken to social
media to share their touching tributes
from guest stars like Morgan Fairchild
to the main cast here's what they had to
say on Friends Maggie wheeler played
Chandler's on again off again girlfriend
Janice off camera wheeler and Perry were
Pals and she was among the first to pay
tribute to him on social media she wrote
on Instagram what a loss the world will
miss you Matthew Perry
the joy you brought to so many in your
Too Short lifetime will live on I feel
so very blessed by every creative moment
we shared Morgan Fair child who played
Chandler's complicated mother Norah
throughout the Run of friends
acknowledged Matthew Perry's death on EX
formerly known as Twitter writing I'm
heartbroken about the untimely death of
my son Matthew Perry the loss of such a
brilliant young GAA is a shock Fair
child went on to offer her thoughts
specifically to John Bennett Perry his
father the Elder Perry worked together
with Fair child on the 1980s soap operas
Flamingo Road and Falcon Crest John
Bennett Perry also appeared on friends
as Mr burin in a season 4 episode it
also seems as if the two shared a close
father some relationship as Matthew
posted a picture of them together on
Instagram recently Selma Blair paid
tribute to Matthew Perry on her
Instagram where she affectionately
referred to her onetime friends co-star
as her oldest boyfriend Blair wrote All
of Us loved Matthew and I did especially
every day I loved him unconditionally
and he me and I'm broken brokee hearted
sweet dreams Matty sweet dreams Blair
played Chandler's flirtatious coworker
Wendy in the episode the one with
Christmas in Tulsa it was a memorable
role that unfortunately didn't recur
throughout the series another famous
Chandler exgirlfriend on friends was
Kathy played by padet Brewster who hung
out with the group during season 4
originally introduced as a new girl
friend for Joey Chandler finds himself
falling in love with her despite all of
his effort eventually culminating in a
scene where she gives him a haircuts and
they kiss did you sleep with her no no
no I just kissed her what that's even
worse this incident nearly destroys the
iconic Bromance between the two
roommates which is only resolved after
Joey makes Chandler sit in a wooden box
and think about what he's done following
this with Joey's blessing Kathy and
Chandler briefly date however their
relationship doesn't work out in the end
roer also shared her response to the
tragic loss of Matthew Perry in a post
to her ex account she shared warm
memories of the actor writing I'm so
very sad to hear about Matthew Perry he
was lovely to me on friends and every
time I saw him in the decades after
please read his book it was his legacy
to help he won't rest in peace though
he's already too busy making everyone
laugh up there two days after news of
Matthew Perry's death came to light the
remaining cast members of friends came
together to honor their friend and
coaster they wrote in their statement to
people we are also utterly devastated by
the loss of Matthew we were more than
just castmates we are a family they
added that they are taking time to
process the loss of Perry and they will
have more to say in the near future the
actors concluded by writing for now our
thoughts and our love are with Matty's
family his friends and everyone who
loved him around the world their
statement came one day after friends
creators Mar kman and David crane as
well as exec itive producer Kevin brigh
released a joint statement of their own
their statement said we will always
cherish the joy the light the blinding
intelligence he brought to every moment
not just his work but in life as well
they also recalled that from the very
beginning they felt Perry was the
absolute perfect fit for the role of
Chandler Bing to say they were right
would be an
[Music]
understatement